[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de VIP aujourd'hui nous recevons
Jean-Jacques Simon dit Jaco une
personnalité ivinoise de 64 ans qui vit
aujourd'hui à Montini le Bretonneux
alors Jacco bonjour alors vous êtes
séropositif depuis
1985 2 ans après la découverte du virus
du sida vous étiez toxicomane à l'époque
racontez-nous un peu plus tôt en fait 82
plus que plus que 85 parce que 85 86
c'est le le test ELISA c'est quand ça a
été officialisé c'est-à-dire que là ils
ont trouvé un test qui qui montrait la
séropositivité et du coup à ce moment-là
j'été j'étais à fleur mes registres ou
je sais plus à bois d'Arc ils nous ont
tous à ce moment-là tous les toxicomanes
on a été vérifié pour voir si on était
justement et c'est là que j'aiété
certifié mais en 82 il m'avait déjà
trouvé à l'hôpital de fren qu'ils
appelaient à l'époque une hyperplasie
lymphoïde bénigne sans traitement c'està
direire que là il y avait pas grandchose
de c'était pas très dangereux quoi il y
a pas besoin de faire médecine he hyper
plasie lymphoïde et bénine ça ça Bénin
c'est rien du tout donc c'est ça quand
ils me l'ont rediagnostiqué après
c'était plus du tout Bénin et ça
s'appelait plus du tout de la même façon
donc on est d'accord 85 officiellement
officiellement 85 ou 86 je sais plus le
test ELISA c'est je sais plus si c'est
85 ou 86 mais c'est dans c'est c'est une
de ces deux années là et comment vous
avez été contaminé racontez-nous en fait
par un voisin à l'époque j'habitais à
Paris la me piqu Grenel je cachais des
matériels pour pour d'injection dans
dans dans une cave des locaux communs et
il y avait un autre toxicomane que je
connaissais d'ailleurs dans l'immeuble
et un jour qui s'est servi sans me
prévenir et tout qui s'est servi de de
mes trucs moi j'étais moi j'étais assez
paranoyque j'allais même cambrioler des
des comment dirais-je des des cabinets
d'infirmière rien que pour avoir des
seringues parce que dans les cabinets
d'infirmièr il y a pas de produit il y a
aucun aucun stupéfiant mais juste pour
avoir des seringues des Garau et des
choses comme ça je faisais ça donc c'est
vraiment un accident je dirais
indépendant de ma volonté sur le coup
alors en 2014 vous avez sorti un livre
intitulé ma place au soleil vous êtes
revenu sur votre maladie sur 150 pages
est-ce que c'était important pour vous
d'en parler à travers un livre ben
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait en 2004 j'avais
fait un premier bouquin et j'avais fait
sur le milieu carcéral vu que j'avais
pas mal bourlingué dans ce milieu-là
dans les années 80 entre la cam et la
prison et donc j'avais fait un livre en
2004 et j'avais trouvé ce format euh
comme j'ai un ami bon Vincent ravalc qui
lui est écrivain mais vraiment écrivain
il m'avait conseillé ce format qui était
pas trop mal le format des nouvelles et
du coup j'avais j'avais fait ce premier
truc ce premier bouquin qui avait été
édité tout ça j'étais content j'avais
fait des salons du livre tout ça ça
c'était super bien passé et du coup euh
à un moment donné j'ai eu l'envie d'en
faire un enfin c'est pas que j'ai eu
l'envie d'en faire un autre c'est une
amie qui a vu un manuscrit que j'avais
gardé que j'avais écrit à une époque
j'écrivais dans vers 2004 j'arrêtais pas
d'écrire elle a vu ce manuscrit qui
avait pas été édité et tout et elle
s'est mis dans la tête qu'il fallait le
faire éditer et tout ça et du coup elle
m'a donné elle m'a renvoyé des des
adresses de maison d'édition et la
deuxième à laquelle j'ai téléphoné ils
m'ont pris ils m'ont accepté et enfin
ils m'ont ils m'ont édité donc du coup
j'ai fait ce deuxième et si la
logique s'applique ça fait 2004 2014 et
normalement je dois faire un l'année
prochaine vous bossez dessus je bosse
pas vraiment on peut pas dire enfin si
si enfin je bosse et je bosse pas
puisque moi ma façon d'écrire c'est la
même façon dont je parle donc si tu veux
je ça peut être raconter ce qu'on a vécu
aujourd'hui après tout dépend comment tu
le racontes c'est ça l'E de l'écrire
écrire enfin je dire tu peux écrire des
trucs personne ENF ça ça percute
personne et puis tu peux l'écrire la
même chose d'une autre façon alors que
les fait les faits sont les mêmes mais
ça va intéresser les gens parce que la
façon d'écrire parce que des voilà et
tout ça et moi j'aime bien parce que
tous les gens qu' eu qu' on lu les
bouquins m'ont tous dit la même chose
ils m'ont dit ça se lit vite c'est
rigolo et on apprend des trucs is C
c'était but donc pour moi c'est nickel
pour moi c'est impeccable et c'
important de parler aussi de de votre
maladie au grand public parce qu'il y a
des gens que vous ne connaissez pas qui
ont acheté le livre sûrement oui mais
c'est enfin moi c'est pas plus important
que ça parce que moi j'ai jamais je dire
en 80 en 93 j'ai rencontré une
journaliste à France 2 elle cherchait
des gens pour parler du sida à visage
découvert et c'est vrai que moi ça me
gênait absolument pas du de parler de de
ça comme ça et tout ça et pour pour
l'époque et tout ça c'était bah pour
elle c'était exceptionnel quoi c'était
personne le faisait et tout ça et moi je
suis toujours parti dans cette idée que
tu as deux possibilité tu as soit tu vas
jouer le la victime et tu vas ENF c'est
pas la victime mais soit tu vas tout te
prendre dans la gueule toutes les
réflexions moi je m'en suis pris des
réflexions je te sers la main pourtant
je te enin des trucs si je te racontais
toi assez incroyable mais moi j'ai
toujours choisi le truc de me dire moi
je c'est pas je le mets même presque en
avant mais c'est je vais pas me cacher
tois parce que il y en a qui ça les
dérange et je m'en fous la terre on est
on est plusieurs milliards sur la
planète donc j'aurai jamais le temps de
voir tout le monde donc de toute façon
je vais pas m'arrêter à ceux qui qui
m'intéressent pas donc je vais en
sortant les choses cach les masques qui
tombent tout de suite je l'ai vu j'étais
magazinier à une époque à Montini dans
une dans un truc d'électroménager
d'électroportatif je veux dire et un
jour j'ai annoncé ma
céropositivité suite à une prime que
j'avais pas touché parce qu'on m'avait
dit que tu manquais d'investissement et
moi je me dis ah c'est bizarre je manque
d'investissement alors que quand
j'arrive le premier du mois je sais pas
si je vais toucher ma paye le 30 parce
que je serais peut-être déjà mort et
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit parce que
j'ai j'ai enterré des potes à moi en une
semaine que j'ai vu le lundi qu' all est
bien et que j'ai enterré le vendredi à
une époque ça tombait comme des mouches
donc quand ils m'ont pas donné cette
prime pourtant c'était que dalle c'était
à l'époque 300 francs mais il me l'ont
pas donné ça m'a choqué je me suis dit
moi je me lève tous les matins alors que
je pourrais rester chez moi même dans ma
situation j'aurais même pas besoin de
venir taer mais j'ai envie d'y aller
j'ai envie donc c'est quand même que je
suis investi il me donne pas le truc
donc je leur ai dit le truc j'ur dit je
les visages ont changé ah bah là mais là
c'est incroyable et en plus ce qui est
incroyable c'est que des gens que je
prenais vraiment pour des des an baté
sont devenus des gens super intéressants
alors que d'autres qui étaient mes plus
proches dans la société sont devenus des
vrais crétins ça fait tomber les façades
ah mais les façades tombent d'une force
tu peux même pas t'imaginer là tu es
c'est incroyable c'est impitoyable alors
dans ce dans ce livre où sur vous parlez
notamment du sida comme étant un singe
pourquoi utiliser ce ce terme mais c'est
la référence des toxico en fait parce
que les toxicos on a toujours on a
toujours cette expression de dire que tu
as un singe accroché à toi c'est la cam
en fait c'est la cam qui qui qui
accroché à toi et c'est ça c'est un peu
ce truc là et moi j'ai j'ai transporté
ça sur le comment
dirais-je c'est moi ça cétait à l'époque
oui on voit les images d'archiv c'est
moi ça c'est moi dans mon quand j'habite
à Fontenel fleur ou je vois très bien
ouais ouais bah ouais c'est ça ouais et
euh faut pas oublier d'ailleurs Didier
là le Chenu là parce que là on voit le
bouquin le premier bouquin il y avait
des comment on appelle ça il y avait des
illustrations dessus c'est c'est un gars
de enfin de qui est pas de Montini mais
qui est de 50 ans en Yveline qui qui
s'appelle le Chenu qui qui a fait toutes
ses qui avait fait toutes ses toutes ses
illustrations ah ouais c'est marrant je
me rappelle j'avais acheté un ordinateur
exprès pour j'avais un des potes à moi
qui j'avais les images des années 2000
si j'étais intermittent en fait j'étais
intermittent et je bossais avec toute
l'équipe de meségaton les mecs ont fait
taken et tout ça taken 2 et tout ça et
je bossais avec eux j'étais je suis amis
avec eux et avec Olivier et on parlait
on parlait il y avait le producteur de
la vie rév des anges il y avait des le
le scénariste de ridicule ridicule c'est
quand même pas rien avec girodo et tout
c'est des textes incroyables ciselé
vraiment et tous ces mecsl m'ont dit
vas-y tu devrais écrire parce que je
leur je parle comme je te parle là et du
coup je leur parlais je leur racontais
des anecdotes de l'époque au placard
dans la rue et tout ça il me disit tu
devrais écrire ça c'est un film ça c'est
un truc ça tu devrais et du coup c'était
à ce moment-là je me rappelle il y a eu
la canicule je me suis j'avais il me
restait 1000 balles à peu près sur mon
sur un P ou je sais pas quoi là je l'ai
j'ai été acheté un Mac avec j'ai acheté
un mac je me suis mis dans mon dans ma
chambre et tout et je je l'ai sorti
d'une d'un seul coup quoi et j'ai eu de
la chance au tout début j'ai fait un peu
j'ai traîné dans ce qu'ils appellent le
triangle d'or la 6e arrondissement et
tout ça là où il y a faayard là où il y
a toutes les grosse boîte d'édition je
leur en ai déposé et tout mais bon il y
a pas eu vraiment de retour sur le enfin
il y a pas vraiment eu de retour là tout
de suite et après j'ai un ami qui qui
habitait aussi à 50 ans fait capitain
hancour à la à la Commanderie il était
il était peintre mais il est il est
Chevalier des arelllettes mais lui il
était à la Commanderie des Templiers à
lancour et il m'a dit bah tiens moi il y
a une maison d'édition pour laquelle je
fais des couvertures il me dit je peux
te donner leurs coordonnées tout ça
éventuellement tu vois avec eux et le
truc qui m'intéressait c'est qu'ils
étaient de la croix de chavau à
Montreuil et moi la croix de chavau à
Montreuil ça me correspond bien mieux
que le 6e arrondissement aéon ou tout ce
que tu veux c'est plus mon quartier tu
me dis 11e arrondissement 19e 18e je
suis chez moi tu me dis 7e
arrondissement tout ça je suis paumé tu
vois c'est voilà et et du coup sachant
que c'était que céit était là-bas j'ai
dit tiens c'est cool je vais les appeler
et tout et en fait 15 jours après ils
m'ont signé ils m'ont signé il m'ont
votreaction c'était quoi ah j'étais
super content en plus ils m'ont donné
2000 balles d'avaloir to vois ça c'était
mortel pour moi j'avais c'était vraiment
une une espèce de reconnaissance et
après c'est une toute petite boîte
d'édition céit un couple en fait mais
l'avantage c'est que j'ai fait tous les
salons du livre avec eux j'ai fait
Colmar Nancy Paris vous en avez vendu
combien au total à peu près mais je les
vendais au porte à porte quasiment parce
que dans les dans les salons dans les
salons le vendredi généralement c'est
scolaire les scolaires qui passe donc tu
voyais les mecs les jeunes passer tout
ça puis tu voyais tous les petits passer
puis il y en avait qui étaient là ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vas-y quoi c'est
quoi ça les écrivain rien à vas-y
c'est de la merde et tout et moi quand
j'envoyais passer comme ça qui se la
raconta je je je la le pagué tu vois
mais de loin je fais oh viens ici il me
dit quoi il me dit moi c'est moi je suis
l'écrivain qui écrit pour les mecs en
baguy moi toi tu tu tu vois ce que je
veux te ou pas tu as pas compris et du
coup ils étaient interpellés tu vois ils
venaient voir et tout et le plus le plus
drôle de ça c'est que deux ou trois fois
ça m'est arrivé au minimum deux fois et
je dirais peut-être même un peu plus il
y a des parents qui sont venus le samedi
ou le dimanche en me disant mon fils
veut acheter un
livre comme si c'était un truc avz votre
objectif céit ouais c'était pour eux
c'était un truc
complètement mon fils va put un livre tu
vois ils étaient choqués tu vois moi ça
me faisait plaisir j'étais content alors
on va on va parler maintenant du
traitement ouais euh du coup vous avez
essayé la trithérapie dès 1993 ouais
ouais aujourd'hui vous en êtes où bah en
fait si tu veux moi j'ai toujours eu un
virus multirésistant c'est-à-dire que
pendant des années des années à chaque
fois que je prenais un traitement ça
marchait pendant quelques mois et après
ça sé croulait il fallait repasser à un
autre
traitement donc ça ça a duré j'en ai
fait je sais pas j'ai dû en faire tr ou
14 grosso modo sur les toutes ces années
et arrivé à un moment que je Seris pe
pas dire exactement quand peut-être
2000 2007 dans les entre 2005 et 2010 je
dirais on a trouvé un traitement et
jusqu'à là on a gardé le même traitement
et là-dessus ça va par contre ils m'ont
découvert une autre maladie congénitale
de ma mère qui est comment dirais-je une
maladie des vaisseaux sanguins des
artères et alors là je te passe je me
suis fait enlever un morceau carotide
ils m'ont ouvert ils m'ont je su ouvert
comme ça ils m'ont ouvert les deux
jambes enfin bon rien à voir avec le
SIDAS rien à voir avec les SIDAS un truc
c'était une prime c'est une prime de
d'héritage de ma mère congénital un
truc et du coup j'ai ces trucs là
maintenant c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'aprèsdemain je vais me faire opérer
encore d'une
jambe mais bon voilà chacun son karma
moi je dis souvent j'ai tendance à dire
aux infirmières je suis une espèce de
terrain d'expérimentation vivant faites
ce que vous voulez de toute manière moi
depuis de depuis le 10 mars 2010 tu vois
qu'est-ce que je dis 2010 depuis le 10
mars 90 date où j'ai shooté la dernière
fois de ma vie tu vois et que je suis
sorti de de prison et que je bon j'ai
shooté le jour où je suis sorti puis
après j'ai arrêté bah depuis ce jour-là
moi c'est du BF tuis enfin c'est
j'attendais pas d'avoir tuis l'an 2000
je l'attendais pas il y a plein de trucs
je l'attendais pas tu vois j'étais pas
moi j'étais pas inquiet par le Big Bang
ou quoi que ce soit parce que je
m'attendais même pas à le passer et
justement vous vous sentez comment un
peu privilégié je sais pas si je peux
dire ça dans dans votre maladie vous
avvez dit que certains se sont décédés
très rapidem ouis euh vous vous êtes
vous êtes encore là B en fait si tu veux
oui parce que le truc là où je me sens
entre guillemets privilégié mais je sais
pas si on peut parler privilégié si
c'est le mot adéquate mais le le truc
c'est que comme j'ai moi le quand je
quand on m'a appris toutes ces histoires
de
céropositivité en fait j'aurais tendance
à dire j'en avais strictement rien à
parce que je savais que à peine
je sortais j'allais shooter donc je
savais je connaissais j'étais pas naïf
je savais où ça me menait c'était soit à
un moment donné j'allais me prendre une
balle parce que j'allais faire un truc
un peu crapuleux et que j'allais me
faire voilà soit j'allais me faire j'en
sais rien une overdose soit j'ai enfin
bref mais mes possibilités elles étaient
un peu restreintes tois j'avais pas
beaucoup de de toi donc plus la maladie
plus tout ça donc je savais je me disais
moi de toute manière on me dit tu es
malade moi si tu veux j'avais toujours
cette image de dire c'est comme si tu
avais toute la famille adamocles qui
était audessus de ma tête et qu' y en
avait un qui essayait de rentrer pour
pousser pour essayer de se faire une
place c'est le sida mais il y avait déjà
c'était déjà blindé au-dessus de ma tête
donc un peu plus un peu moins ça me tu
vois ça me touchait pas du tout mais le
truc c'est que comme ce sidà je m'en
suis servi entre guillemets pour avancer
tois de plutôt que de me bloquer dessus
et de de paranoyer dessus tois je m'en
suis servi pour avancer du coup ça m'a
comment dirait ça m'a donné une
motivation pour changer ma vie tu vois
pour que ma vie elle change de ce que
j'étais quand j'étais é toxico s'il y
avait pas eu ce déclic d'ê voir cette
maladie là je sais pas si je serais
j'aurais bougé les choses je seraai
sûrement rester de tuis sur ma lancée et
je me serais flingué d'une façon ou
d'une autre quoi je pense parce que je
commenais à rentrer quand même dans de
la délinquence qui était quand même un
peu plus élevée tu vois c'est ça
commença à être un petit peu plus
dangereux au quotidien quoi on va parler
maintenant de la dépénalisation du
cannabis vous êtes un fervant militant
la dépénalisation notamment au niveau
thérapeutique bah c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'est rendu compte par la force des
choses tant qu'on tant qu'on étudiait
pas la plante on pouvait pas le savoir à
partir du moment où on s'est mis à
étudier la plante on a commencé à avoir
des ouvertures par rapport au CBD par
rapport à d'autres composant de la
plante qui font que je dirais pas je
vais pas aller faire comme ils font sur
facebook certains qui te mettent
cannabis cure cancer tois le cannabis
guérit le cancer c'est de la pure
connerie nous en plus dans l'association
dont je fais partie dit on n'arrête pas
de recevoir des coups de téléphone de de
moment de en panique mon fils a le
cancer na na na j'ai lu que on pouvait
soignner le parce que les gens quand ils
sont acculés qu'ils ont plus de solution
ils sont prêts à plein de choses le côté
à cannabis c'est interdit si ton fils il
a le cancer et qu'on te dit que le
cannabis il va guérir le cancer tu en as
plus rien à que le cannabis il
soit interdit tu vas t'en servir parce
que ton fils il est malade donc ce Tru
il y a des gens qui font par contre il y
a des gens qui font un peu n'importe
quoi par par contre dire que le cannabis
peut dans certains cas adoucir
ou permettre toi par pour l'appétit moi
je vais m'en servir par rapport à
l'appétit je peux moi je peux ne pas
manger moi le ramadan ça me gêne pas à
part de mais en plus je fume plus
tellement mais je peux faire le ramadan
ça me gêne pas du tout je je peux rester
sans sans manger pendant longtemps mais
si je mange pas pendant longtemps au
bout d'un moment ma santé va s'en
ressentir to vois donc il faut que je
mange et ben ça le cannabis va m'aider
tu vois ça m'ouvre la appétit ça va
m'aider aussi bien bizarrement pour
dormir que pour le matin me lever ben
c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est voilà
donc moi je je c'est comme ça je vais
pas chercher plus loin que ça et
simplement je me dis que pourquoi
empêcher les gens de se so enfin de de
comment dirais-je de se soulager avec ça
alors qu'il y a plein d'autres produits
qui sont qui sont utilisés dans la dans
la pharmacopé comme la morphine les
opioïdes et tout je veux dire on donne
des opioïdes on donne du fantany ou des
des des des oxycodons et tout ça à des
gens c'est des ça fait des ça fait des
vagu de de de mort aux États-Unis c'est
c'est un scandale sanitaire aux
États-Unis et ça ça commence à arriver
chez nous ça ça dérange personne par
contre pour donner des autorisations de
mise sur le marché par contre pour avoir
une autorisation de mise sur le marché
pour du cannabis ah bah alors là c'est
la c'est la croix et la bannière désolé
hein JAC on est on est pressé un peu par
le temps je
sais dernière question votre regard sur
la maladie aujourd'hui 174000 Français
vivent avec le VIH en France et 38,4
million dans le monde qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez bah déjà sur les 38 millions
tu en as un paquet déjà c'est des
insolvables hein c'est ceux que c'est
les pays où il y a pas de tune pour
pouvoir acheter des des médicaments et
tout ça donc là forcément il y a il y a
plus de et en France 1 France moi chez
nous j'ai pour pour pour pour
synthétiser le truc j'ai une anecdote
c'est que là récemment j'étais à
l'hôpital et normalement à l'hôpital on
te dit ne prends aucun médicament tous
les médicaments vont Têtre donnés par
l'hôpital il te le il te le mettent sur
une ordonnance et mais toi tu as pas le
droit d'amener tes médicaments moi moi
j'écoute ce qu'on me dit he j'amène pas
mes médicaments to j'arrive là-bas je
suis resté 3 jours sans avoir une sur
les trois molécules que j'ai puisque
maintenant j'ai plus que trois molécules
pour la trithérapie avant j'en ai eu
qure et des fois même C mais là j'en ai
trois il en avait une qui me manquait
bah pendant 3 jours je l'ai pas eu ils
ont pas été la chercher nulle part à une
époque dans les années 90 tu même pas
t'envisager c'est un truc comme ça les
médicaments sida c'était le truc là ils
en ont plus rien là le sida c'est devenu
un espèce de truc ils en ont mais
quasiment plus rien à pour être
toi un petit coup de gueule là-dessus ah
bah un petit coup de gueule moi si tu
veux plutôt que de faire un coup de
gueule j'amène mes mé moi je veux dire
moi tu sais jeis je je m'adapte au truc
les gens tu peux pas retourner toute la
connerie humaine parce que je veux dire
elle elle prend trop de de puissance et
tout donc mieux vaut essayer de louvoyer
entre les trucs ils te disent voilà tu
sais que ça va être comme ça tu ramènes
tes médoes et puis tu tu tu prends pas
la tête avec eux et et puis voilà comme
ça c'est c'est tranquille autrement un
coup de gueule un coup de gueule je peux
pas me permettre de dire que j'ai un
vrai gros coup de gueule dans la mesure
où on s'est quand même bien occupé de
moi faut quand même si que je suis là
aujourd'hui j'étais là ici a quel plus
d'une dizaine ou une quinzaine d'années
déjà les images qu'on a vu tu vois une
vingtaine d'années
même je peux pas me plaindre je je suis
j'habite à montinille Bretonneux c'est
une ville qui est super chouette les
gens sont les gens il y en a qui se
bagarrent pour venir j'avais lu sur le
journal pour les HLM ici les gens se
bagarrent pour
venir j'ai bossé ici il m'ont accueilli
m'ont laissé bosser j'ai bossé avec des
ados je me suis éclaté j'ai j'ai fait
plein de projets avec des ados et tout
ça à la maison quartier quand je
travaillais animateur au pas du lac
là je suis dans un endroit sympa il a tu
vois c'est pas avec ce que j'ai moi
cotisé à la à la société que normalement
tu as plein de pays te renvoi rien quand
tu as cotisé ce que moi j'ai cotisé pour
la société tu es aux États-Unis je suis
autour d'un bidon en train de chanter du
blues tu vois avec il fait froid tu vois
mais il y a ici c'est quand même un peu
plus cool quoi merci Jacob c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission merci pour votre
témoignage on aurais pu parler pendant
des heures com votre personnalité de
votre histoire on aurait pu parler de de
tout ça pendant pendant des heures
malheureusement cette émission là doit
se terminer alors votre livre ma place
au soleil publié aux éditions max Milot
merci Jacco à bientôt pour un VIP
bientôt